dokic eev ce qu'est dans la banlieue de
kharkiv a été pilonnée par les troupes
russes pendant un mois dont le parc de
l'université une boule à leurs munitions
n'a pas explosé
cette arme est interdite par de nombreux
pays
il n'y avait que des civils ici pas de
militaires c'est un crime de la russie
et de son armée
ce campus est presque vide
le silence des lieux n'est troublé que
par les tirs d'artillerie à quelques
kilomètres au nord
sous les bombardements une centaine de
villageois s'ils sont quand même réfugié
faute de mieux il vanne les a aidés à se
cacher dans le sous-sol de l'université
ils y vivent depuis deux mois
je porte ce poids sur la poitrine en
permanence on veut rentrer chez nous
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait désir et
d'autres nous sommes cachés ici mais
pour combien de temps encore et nous
devons nous aller ensuite
il vanne fait le tour des hameaux
voisins pour prendre des nouvelles de
leurs habitants
toute la communauté mobilisée depuis le
début de la guerre cela va à fermer son
magasin de fournitures de bureau et
apporte de l'aide aux villageois tous
terrés dans leurs abris pendant plus
d'un mois d'occupation
merci de ne pas nous avoir oublié
ils continuent à venir nous voir malgré
les risques et les mines
originaire de mal à roanne cela va ne
peut plus y vivre
les soldats russes ont saccagé sa maison
ils ont même vécu dans sa cave
il y avait 20 bouteille de 3 litres de
vodka que j'avais fais moi-même ici et
ils ont tous vu les quelques villageois
déjà de retour tente de rendre possible
la vie sur place les corps des soldats
russes abandonnés dans les rues sont
enterrés mais impossible pour l'heure
d'envisager un retour à la normale il
est toujours extrêmement difficile pour
les civils devenir serez installé de
manière permanente dans cette zone les
combats font toujours rage à quelques
kilomètres par ici les troupes
ukrainienne tente de repousser l'armée
russe vers son pays et par ici c'est la
ville d'izu ou au lieu des combats
extrêmement important en ce moment les
ukrainiens ont réussi à reprendre le
contrôle de cette route qui coupe les
approvisionnements russes en direction
de cette ville et ce qui est bien en
pêche leur progression en direction du
dombass dans cette zone alors il est
extrêmement important pour les troupes
l'ukrainienne de parvenir à garder le
contrôle de cette région